What are the major secrets of success is
always knew more than you're paid for
and then you will always be paid more
than what you're getting now.
And number six,
you must use your time well every
minute,
every hour,
every day.
Remember,
this life is not a rehearsal for
anything else in life.
This is the real thing.
The purpose of this course is not to
make you an expert,
but to give you the tools of all
experts,
all successful people in business.
I'm going to hit these points reasonably
rapidly.
I've made a decision that what you want
is the greatest amount of practical,
usable information in the shortest
period of time.
You are quite capable in your own
business and in your own activities to
take this material away and select from
it what you need at the moment.
You must have a very,
very strong desire to be successful in
business in order to attempt the
business enterprise.
It's like embarking on a journey across
an uncharted ocean because no matter
what you start off with as a compass or
a destination,
the tides and the winds are going to
change your direction very,
very quickly.
It must have very,
very strong desire.
You must really,
really want to be independent.
You must really want a ton of me.
You must want the freedom.
You must want the success because you're
going to be buffeted by the storms of
business life and without a very,
very intense desire.
You're going to be washed overboard.
The second thing that you have to have
is you have to have very clear burning,
compelling goals to which you're
committed.
You have to be able to determine exactly
what it is you want to accomplish in
terms of income,
in terms of business growth,
where you want to be in one,
three,
five,
10 years and you have to make sure that
everything you're doing on a day to day
basis is consistent with your goals.
One of the things we have found is that
if you are not doing something that
contributes to achieving your aim,
then what you're doing probably detracts
from achieving your aim and one of the
major reasons for failure in life is the
inability to focus single mindedly on
one thing at a time.
I'll talk about this over and over as we
go through the course.
As a matter of fact,
everything in this course is aimed at
giving you the targets,
the pinpoint targets for you to focus on
in each area of business development.
What are the key things that you have to
hone in on and concentrate on in order
to be successful?
The next thing is belief.
You must absolutely believe yourself to
be capable in this field.
One of the things that we find is that
in business,
some people are unique and have
remarkable talents and couldn't do
phenomenal things in a short period of
time,
but the great majority of business
people,
80 or 90% are of primarily average
intelligence.
They are not great geniuses.
They don't have extraordinarily high Iq
is but they do have a very strong belief
in themselves and their ability to
succeed.
They don't believe themselves especially
to be inferior to anybody else and they
don't believe that other people are
especially more talented or more capable
and they are.
In my years of experience,
I have sometimes heard about business
organizations and heard about business
people running these organizations and
how phenomenally talented they must be
and then when I go to work to consult
with these organizations and I spent
hours with these same people that you
read about in the newspapers,
I sit down and I find that really quite
ordinary people,
they just happened to be focused or
specialized along a particular line and
happen to be doing things a little bit
different than other people are doing
and we can think of all kinds of
examples of that.
John D Rockefeller said that the two
most important requirements for business
success or patients and foresight,
but especially patients,
and we'll talk about this a few times,
if you do not have patients,
you can't be successful in business
because almost everything in business is
timing.
There's a too soon and there's a too
late.
And sometimes as business people,
we always want things to soon,
we always want things to happen at least
a year in advance of their scheduled
time.
And very often we push and we press to
make things happen early and it causes
nothing but difficulties.
And of course the ability to delay
gratification.
We live in a society where everybody
wants everything.
Now.
We live in a society where we have been
raised on television,
which means that they're 30 60 and 90
minutes solutions to all the great
problems of life.
And we have a tendency as adults having
grown up with 20 or 30 years of
television to always be looking for
quick solutions.
We see all our life that the most
fundamental and complex problems of
human existence are solved in those
short TV segments.
And they're very most we're willing to
bear as a miniseries.
We have to realize that sometimes people
problems,
market problems take a long time.
I remember I was in a very,
very tight fix in business.
We had over ordered,
we had bought too much of a particular
product.
We had overextended our lines of credit
and the person that I was working for,
we we're talking about whether or not we
had,
if you like,
ruined the possibilities of the company.
I never forget him saying,
Brian,
it's too early to tell.
I said,
well,
we've been in business for six months.
He said,
six months is not enough in the
marketplace.
He said,
we have to wait.
Let's give it another few months.
Now.
Interesting enough,
as a young person,
as an aggressive impetuous person,
another few months seemed like a
lifetime,
but as it happened another few months
was the difference between failure and
tremendous success for that business.
It just took a little bit longer for the
business to get into the marketplace.
One of the things that we always make a
mistake with is we think when we
introduced a new product,
because we know it's a great product,
everybody's going to buy,
everybody's gonna recognize the same
thing.
We recognize however,
people change their opinions and their
ideas toward products very,
very slowly.
Sometimes you have to be in the
marketplace for three months,
six months,
nine months,
a year,
two years,
three years before the product finally
takes off.
Home computers is a perfect example.
Like Ibm decided there was no future in
the home computer market and so they
decided to stay out of it completely,
but suddenly the market exploded and
everybody came to different conclusions.
And finally you'll find that one of the
keys to success in business is what is
called method.
Working systematically,
patiently doing the right things,
right?
Dotting the i's,
crossing the t's,
and then doing them as quickly as
possible are the basic elements.
And if you keep doing the right things
in the right way,
over time,
you must be successful over time.
You put all the odds on your side.
And believe me,
every single thing we talk about in this
course,
I have either done wrong and it's cost
me a lot of money,
or I've worked with corporations who
have done them wrong,
and many of those corporations have gone
bankrupt as a result and lost
everything.
And when I used to hear some of these
things,
I'd say,
well,
I don't particularly like that.
That's not convenient.
That doesn't fit with my schedule.
So I would ignore that point.
I would say,
well,
I'll ignore that point and the rule
won't apply to me.
Just this once.
And when you've ended up selling your
house and selling your car in order to
pay your bills because the market didn't
allow you to get away with it,
even once,
then you learn the lesson next time you
say,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
So finally,
the final analysis,
it's not what you do,
but who you are that makes the
difference in success.
So those are the internal,
the personal qualities,
intense desire,
intense goals,
intense belief in your ability to
succeed,
continuing drive patients and the
ability to delay gratification.
The opportunity area that we're in
today,
and this is the one of the greatest
areas of opportunity in the history of
the world is that we have entered into
the age of the entrepreneur as well as
the age of the intrepreneur if you like,
which we'll talk about in a second,
but there are more corporations being
formed now in our country than at any
other period in history and the rate of
company formation is accelerating
dramatically and this is only the
registered corporations.
The number of sole proprietorships and
partnerships that are forming that don't
even get registered in the corporate
registries is absolutely astronomical.
It's up something like 500% over the
last 20 years.
Today in North America,
there are something like a million
businesses alone being incorporated
every year.
20 years ago it was 200,000 businesses a
year.
Now,
of all those businesses,
80% will fail in the first four to five
years.
This is a part of a dynamic economy.
One of the purposes of this course is to
make sure that your business doesn't
fail and that if you're in business and
your business is not as prosperous as
you'd like it to be,
that it become more prosperous rather
than less prosperous of over 800,000
millionaires in North America,
over 80% of them are self made.
Over 80% of those millionaires started
off with nothing penniless,
with an idea,
a product or a service,
and they built their business to the
point where it is today.
And we know by examining the careers and
the lives of most self made millionaires
that there are certain things that they
did and they're all in this course.
We find that there are three major
reasons why so many businesses fail.
Number one is lack of knowledge.
People don't know how to run a business
successfully.
Number two is lack of support.
They cannot get the support they need
from their suppliers,
from their creditors,
from their bankers,
from their friends,
from their customers and so on.
And number three is lack of capital,
lack of money.
They cannot get enough money to tide
them.
Over the inevitable tough times.
The purpose of this course,
the key objective of this course is to
give you the knowledge necessary to be
able to get the support and the capital
that you require.
We know that it is not a terribly
difficult matter to borrow funds for a
good business idea.
If you know how to put together a
business plan,
every single commercial bank in our
society is there for one specific
reason,
which is to make loans to business.
They'd like to make loans to consumers
that like to make loans on homes.
But basically their reason is to make
good business loans.
And if you have the knowledge necessary
to put together the right business plan
and the right business program,
you will be able to make the
applications to raise,
uh,
the various finances.
And not only that,
it is the knowledge of doing the right
things and doing right things right.
That gets you the support necessary in
order to generate the markets,
to get the suppliers to back you in
order to get the capital in order to
produce the product or service and so
on.
So they all tie together,
but the knowledge must come first and
more people fail from lack of knowledge
and for any other reason.
All right.
What are the key requirements for
business success?
As we say,
business is an art as well as a science.
It's a matter of practical experience,
judgement,
foresight,
and luck.
Really successful in business.
You must never forget the basics.
I was thinking last night that a
business is like a child.
Every single child is unique and
distinct.
It has unique and distinct influences
working on it.
It develops a unique personality and no
matter how many children you have and
have two children in the same and you
only have two people the same in the
world,
businesses are exactly the same.
They all require a certain amount of
nurturing,
caring,
support,
consideration,
growth.
They all have phases that they go
through from infancy through to
adolescence and adulthood and so on.
And interestingly enough,
because business is so big and so
important in western society,
hundreds of millions,
if not billions of dollars have been
spent studying of businesses.
There are enormous faculties and some of
the most intelligent men and women in
the world are working simply fulltime,
40 50 hours a week studying what makes
successful businesses work.
And so it is possible just like there
are many thousands of psychologists,
nurses,
doctors and so on working on studying
what makes healthy children healthy,
happy,
confident.
There are ways to raise healthy
children.
There's waste to retail the business.
So what are the basics of business
success?
Number one role of business in a free
society is to organize and coordinate
the factors of production to produce the
goods and services that people want at
prices.
They are willing and able to pay the
role of business,
especially the role of the business
leader,
the entrepreneur is to combine resources
to take men materials,
labor,
capital and so on.
Combined them into products and services
and get them to the market in size and
shapes,
qualities and quantities that people
want to buy,
are willing to buy.
All businesses that are successful are
doing that,
right?
All businesses that are unsuccessful are
doing it wrong.
The second thing is that that it is the
wants,
needs and desires of the customers that
determine all business activity.
It is not what producers produce,
but it is what customers want.
That determines business activity.
In other words,
if a company is producing what customers
want and producing it in a cost
efficient and effective way,
then it will grow and prosper.
If a company is not growing and
prospering and that's the first corolla
rate and it means it is not producing
the goods and services that people want.
In other words,
it's always us.
We are always personally as business
people responsible for the success or
lack of success of our enterprise.
Either we're doing it right and if we're
doing it right,
the marketplace will tell us if we're
doing it wrong.
The marketplace will tell us,
and it's always like people in the
marketplace that know what's right,
don't know what's best as customers for
the same services we want at the very
most for the very least,
and we are also ruthless,
selfish,
demanding and this oil.
In other words,
if anybody can offer it to us cheaper,
better,
faster,
we'll buy it from them.
We have people who will work for a
company or work with a company,
buy from a company for 20 years and a
new company will spring up on the block
and they all transfer their business
across the street to that company.
I remember when I was doing some work in
the financial industry,
I found that if one financial
institution raised its deposit rates by
an eighth of a percent,
it would be like tilting a big tub of
water.
That money and deposits would start to
flow to it from all other financial
institutions.
That's why even an eighth of a percent
makes a big difference.
A person could deal with a bank or a
trust company or a savings and loan for
20 years.
The instant that another savings and
loan offers an eighth of a percent more,
they'll walk right across the street
with their money for that eighth of a
percent and this is just the way we are
as human beings.
We all want to be better off in the
future.
Then we are in the present.
Therefore,
every action we take is to improve our
condition.
Very important.
And since we are always acting to
improve our condition,
we always want to improve our condition
in the very most possible.
If somebody is buying from us,
it's because they have come to the
conclusion that all things being equal,
what we are offering is at that moment
and at that time better than what
anybody else is offering.
If they are not buying from us,
they have made the decision that what we
are offering is not as good as what
somebody else is offering.
Very important.
We'll talk about this in marketing.
Well,
we know that,
uh,
customers always make rational
decisions,
which means that customers are always
right.
I'm always,
always find it interesting when I talked
to business people and business people
say,
well,
you know,
these customers just don't understand
what they're missing.
They don't understand.
Customers are stupid.
They don't see that what we're offering
them is the very best they could get
through the very finest quality,
the very cheapest.
No,
no customers or very smart customers are
brilliant.
In fact,
customers are geniuses.
Customers can discern the right
differences every single day of the
week,
and it is never the customer who is
wrong.
It's always the businessperson.
This is one of the hallmarks of
successful businesses.
They say,
if we're not selling enough,
if we're not doing enough business,
it's because of something that we're
doing.
It's certainly not the marketplace.
We all,
we know in a dynamic market,
there are always opportunities for those
who can find new,
better,
faster,
cheaper ways to serve customers with
what they want.
Many of the largest firms in the world
today did not exist 10 years ago.
There are many billion dollar
organizations that they were not even in
a person's mind 10 years ago,
and there are many billion dollar
organizations of 10 and 20 years ago
that don't exist anymore or that exists
in greatly reduced form.
We live,
if you like,
in a dynamic market,
there are always companies and
individuals coming up.
There are always companies and
individuals going down.
It's always happening.
We see it with changing economy,
changing demands,
change and trends and so on.
As long as they're a customer needs
unmet or better or cheaper ways to meet
them.
There are money making opportunities for
the creative and rt,
which means that as long as people don't
have everything they want in life,
there are always opportunities to start
and build successful businesses.
The only question is do we take the time
to find out what it is that people want?
They're always business opportunities
for those who are willing to lower their
prices.
In other words,
to offer new products or services or to
change your customers.
We've had,
uh,
done a lot of research on employment and
we find that one of the things that
stops individuals who are unemployed
from getting reemployed on of the major
things is they keep insisting that they
want to do what they were doing before
they got laid off or before their
industry collapsed and they want to keep
on doing that.
And then when somebody to hire them to
do that here in this place where they
are living because it's convenient for
them,
they don't realize that in order to get
reemployed as an individual,
if your industry is changing,
if your skills are becoming obsolete for
one reason or another,
in order to become reemployed,
you have to restructure what you're
offering.
You have to either offer it to new
markets,
you have to change your wage levels.
You have to demand less.
I've counseled with people who said,
I was already $30,000 a year and I got
laid off and I cannot find another job.
I said,
Oh,
do you mean you cannot find another job?
So I've been everywhere.
I can't find another job.
I said,
therapeutical hiring in your industry.
Oh yes,
they're hiring,
but they're only paying $20,000 a year.
I said,
do you know why?
what has happened is that the market
value of the service you offer has
dropped to $20,000 a year.
It's no longer 30 you may have been paid
30 under unique circumstances,
but where do you have a better
opportunity to earn $30,000 trudging the
streets looking for a job that's not
there or taking a job at $20,000 and
increasing your value with companies?
We often find that we offer our products
and services at the very most that we
can get for those products and services,
but sometimes the market will take a
Kaboom and the price will drop out of
our products and services if we continue
to demand the same prices where we
continue to try to sell the same
products at the same price as to the
same markets.
Very often the market was saying,
I'm sorry,
I'm not interested.
Often we have to lower our prices.
Often we have to change our customers.
One thing I'd like to point out is that
a business enterprise is like a bundle
of resources as a bundle of resources.
It can be turned in any direction.
It is a bundle of capabilities,
talents.
It can be turned to manufacturing and
selling dolls.
It can be turned in another direction to
manufacturing,
producing computers.
It can go into real estate development.
It can market food products.
In something like 70 or 80% of all the
businesses that we surveyed,
we found that the people who achieve the
greatest success in entrepreneurial
activities did not achieve them in the
areas where they first started.
They achieved them in areas different
from what they started.
The most important single skill in
business is the ability to get the goods
out of the woods and move them to the
end.
Consumer accompanied can absorb mistakes
in every single area of endeavor,
but it cannot absorb mistakes in
marketing because if marketing stops,
the company stops to profits are always
a result.
Profits are not the objective.
People who start into business with the
goal of serving customers well by giving
them the products or services they want
or usually successful and and the
profits follow customers pay all wages,
not corporations and everyone has at
least one customer.
One of the things that we have to ask
over and over again is who is our
customer?
Who is your customer?
Who do I have to satisfy in order to be
successful?
And then as you'll see as we go on a
little bit later,
who is my biggest customer?
Who do I have to satisfy the most in
order to be the most successful?
I used to work for the chairman of a
large conglomerate,
which I mentioned before and very early
in my career with the chairman,
even though I was doing about five or
six things simultaneously,
I made the decision that I had only one
customer and that organization and that
customer was the chairman.
And as long as I satisfied that
customer,
I could be slow or slack or make
mistakes in any area.
But as long as this chairman was happy,
everything would be fine.
If I did brilliantly in every area,
but I didn't satisfy the chairman,
I was going to be in serious trouble and
I'd suggest that has a very,
very good strategy or your success will
always be determined by what you do,
the demand for your product or service,
and the difficulty of replacing you.
The most important thing is how valuable
is your service to other people?
How valuable is it?
You can tell how valuable it is by how
much people are willing to pay you for
it.
And the same strategies adhere here
inside a corporation,
doing everything possible to increase
the value of what you do for your
company makes you a more valuable
person.
Xerox had an advertisement that came out
some years ago and the advertisement
showed I sort of a little cartoon.
At the first cartoon,
there was a little boy with the lemonade
stand,
said lemonade,
5 cents a glass scrawled on a sign.
And he's sitting there with a picture
and some glasses and it's shows on
another little boy walking up and
setting up his own lemonade stand next
door to compete.
And his little sign said lemonade,
5 cents a glass.
And then it shows the two of them
looking at each other.
So here they have the identical product
with the identical stand.
And then the last little caption showed
the second person who had entered the
lemonade market with a rose in each
glass.
And it says when people compete products
and get better.
So in other words,
he had added a little bit of something
special and it was the little bit extra
that made all the difference.
Well,
if you wish to earn more,
you must concentrate on increasing the
value of your services that you will
always be rewarded in direct proportion
for what you do and the value of what
you do.
Your whole job in life is simply,
this is to increase your value,
do everything possible to increase your
value.
Listening to tapes like this is a very,
very important investment in your
future.
Well,
the market only pays superior rewards
for superior goods and services.
It pays average rewards for average
goods and services and it pays inferior
rewards for inferior goods and services.
And it's a very,
very important,
and we talk about this in the session on
strategic marketing,
it's very important to identify what is
it that you do in an excellent fashion.
What is it that you would do that is so
good,
that's so special that you're better
than anybody else was doing it because
unless you can answer that question,
you're not ready to go into business.
Well.
The next is that it's business success
comes from direct developing excellence
in a particular market related area.
I give you a perfect example of
developing excellence.
Ibm and one of my favorite examples is
one of the most successful companies in
the world.
IBM has developed excellence in a
particular area and that is service.
They've developed excellence in a key
area and the market pays them a premium
year after year,
makes them one of the most profitable
and most successful companies on earth
and it's because they recognize very
early in business that service was a a
key consideration to the marketplace.
Everybody would rather have leisure than
hard work.
There is a great demand,
a great desire within the human soul to
take it easy to put up your feet,
to retire,
to relax,
to just take it easy.
However it is the successful people who
pay the extra price,
go the extra mile,
do the extra little things,
make the extra habits to get up extra
early in the morning,
go to the extra courses,
read the extra books and so on.
Those are the keys to success in
business.
It's always doing the little bit extra
and you always know that if you are
contributing greater value than you're
taking out,
then you know that you are always
growing in success and you're always
growing in income.
If you're only contributing exactly as
much as you're taking out,
that means you're staying.
Even if you're contributing less than
what you're taking out,
it means that you're falling behind.
So the master key to riches is self
discipline.
What are the seven personal qualities
that assured success in business?
Number one,
you must know yourself and know exactly
what it is you want in life.
Goal orientation is an essential
requirement of all successful people and
as we'll talk about later,
we know lack of goal orientation goes
hand in hand with failure and every
single walk of life,
somebody should be able to wake you up
at three o'clock in the morning and
asked you what is your major definite
purpose in life?
What is your number one goal?
What do you want to accomplish more than
anything else in the next three to five
years?
And you should be able to wake up out of
a sound sleep and tell that person
instantly.
You must know it crystal clear.
We know that our goals always determine
the direction that we go in life.
I was reading something by thorough last
night.
It says that you should go confidently
in the direction of your dreams.
It says that try to live the life that
you have imagined for yourself and you
will be astonished at how far and how
fast you actually go in life if you
always tried to live consistent with
your dreams about yourself for the
future.
And Conrad Hilton said that you've got
to have a dream if you want to make a
dream come true.
Most self made millionaires compare
themselves to billionaires.
Most people starting their businesses
compare themselves to millionaires,
but once they get to be a millionaire
status,
they start to compare themselves to
billionaires.
And I think Jesus,
look how poorly I'm doing in comparison
to the billionaires,
but in every case,
it's the vision that is the activating
force.
The greater,
the more compelling,
the more burning that division,
that idea of where you want to go and
what you want to do.
We find that companies that achieved
great things always have somebody in the
company who has a mission,
the wants to do something really
important.
I was talking to a gentleman at the
university and not long ago who spent 25
years from the time he entered
biochemistry in his late teens.
He spent 25 years and his whole dream in
life was to make a major contribution to
DNA research,
the basic molecule of all of human life.
That's all they wanted to do.
And for 25 years he had that as a vision
and as a mission and in the 25th year he
made a major breakthrough,
which is now put him in line for a Nobel
prize and you'll probably go down in
history as one of the great biochemist
of the century and this is what kept the
person going for 25 years was the
mission,
the ability to focus,
very important.
The ability to focus as we've said and
we'll say over again is the absolute
critical requirement for success in
business to set targets and to aim at
those targets.
People say,
Jeez,
I don't know if I can be as successful
as other people are because they have
more advantages and more benefits and
more intelligence and so on.
Don't you believe it?
A person who is focused of average
intelligence can run circles around a
person who is a genius,
doesn't have the focus.
That is why people come out of the
universities with phd degrees and with
master's degrees and with sometimes five
10 15 years of advanced education and
they can barely make a living and other
people quit school in grade 10 and grade
11 and they come out of school and five
or 10 years later they have their own
successful businesses.
It's not the basic talents,
although talents are important and
education is important.
It's the ability to focus the talents
that you have,
like a an arrow,
if you like,
like a sniper to be able to hit specific
targets and that's why you don't have to
think of yourself in terms of
limitations.
Many of us hesitate about going ahead in
business because we think that somehow
we lack the talents and abilities.
We look at other people who are
successful in their businesses and we
think those people must have unique
capabilities.
It's only when you get to know these
people and meet these people that you
begin to realize that they're no
different from you or I.
The only difference between a successful
business person or let us say a person
who was launched the business in one who
is not,
is what is the person who launched the
business has done it.
A person who has not has not,
and I've seen this by studying,
if you'd like hundreds if not thousands
of entrepreneurs.
All right.
The next personal quality that assures
success as you must determine the price
that you will have to pay in order to be
successful and then resolve to pay that
price for every single thing you want in
life.
There's a price,
there's a price to has to be paid and
nature always demands of the price to be
paid in advance and the price in
business success is invariably hard,
hard work.
In order to be successful in business,
you have to work hard.
In order to be very,
you have to work harder.
In order to be even more successful,
Still,
there is no substitute for hard work in
business.
Many people say,
well,
these,
look at that person.
They got the right to sell or distribute
a product or service and they made it in
three or four or five years.
You never realize that behind the
scenes,
that person was probably working 1618
hours a day probably for five years
before they got their break in five
years after they got their break.
All you see at the end result is the
Nice House and a nice car.
I reason I mentioned this is sometimes
people start a business,
they think,
well,
I'm sure I'll have to work a couple of
extra hours a day.
Uh,
and as somebody once told me,
when you start your own business,
you only have to work half the time.
You only have to work half days from
then on and you can decide which 12
hours it's going to be.
In a recent study,
they found that in our society you work
eight hours a day for survival and
everything over that you work for
success.
If you're only working eight hours a
day,
you won't do anything more than survive
every additional hour.
Whether you're working for yourself or
someone else is for success.
And so it's very important that you keep
putting in those additional hours,
whether it's extra reading,
extra study,
extra work.
There are many universities and many
psychologists and professors who have
studied millionaires.
They make this a business.
I've studied millionaires,
interviewing them,
bringing them together,
uh,
looking at their lifestyles,
looking at their habits to find out what
they have in common.
One thing they all have in common is
that they are always thinking about
business and they work extremely hard.
Number three characteristic is self
responsibility.
You have to accept a hundred percent
responsibility for your life and for
everything that you are or ever will be.
Our great old saying if it's to be,
it's up to me,
very important.
The acceptance of personal
responsibility for everything that
happens too is the hallmark of the truly
mature,
truly successful peak performing
individual.
And the opposite of accepting full
responsibility is making excuses.
And many people have said that making
excuses is a disease that is faithful to
success.
No matter what difficulty or handicap
you may have,
there is somebody else who has had far
greater difficulties or handicaps than
you who has gone on to be very
successful.
And there are probably thousands of
people who have had difficulties in
handicap,
is far greater than any you will ever
imagine in life.
And they've gone on to be successful in
life.
So remember,
there's no excuses.
That's the key to maturity is that
You must make a total commitment to your
success.
Burn your bridges.
Total commitment is absolutely essential
in order to be successful in anything.
My friend Charlie Jones,
the great humorous says that the two
keys to success are simply this set
goals he says,
and then make a total commitment to
achieving those goals and then that
nothing dissuade you.
Burn your bridges behind you and let
nothing dissuade you from going for that
goal.
Don't try to straddle.
I've seen many people who have started a
business on the side and then what they
tried to do is they tried to stay with
their main line of work and they've
tried to make their business successful
too and do you know what happens?
Almost invariably their work
deteriorates to the point where their
employment is threatened and they lose
their money and their business.
One of the things that I found over and
over again,
and I've been told this by hundreds of
people,
is that businesses required tremendous,
tremendous,
total commitment and full time
commitment.
Number five,
you must be willing to work hard to go
the extra mile and to always do more
than you're paid for.
One of the major secrets of success is
always do more than you're paid for and
then you will always be paid more than
what you're getting now.
And number six,
you must use your time well every
minute,
every hour,
every day.
Remember this life is not a rehearsal
for anything else in life.
This is the real thing.
And all successful business people,
all self made millionaires look upon
their time as a resource and they're
very careful with it.
They spend their time the way they would
spend money.
And finally,
number seven,
back your plans with determination and
persistence and resolve in advance that
you'll never give up experiment and to
develop new products and processes
within the company.
And if they come up with something,
they can often become the head of the
division to manufacture that particular
product.
Three m will actually create a business
around people who come up with new
products and services.
Every single company today needs men and
women who are talented and who will stay
within the company with their talents
and skills,
but the same requirements that are
necessary for entrepreneurship,
innovation,
daring risk taking.
And so on are also required for
entrepreneurship.
Many of the people that we have studied
who have become extremely successful and
become extremely wealthy in business are
people who never started a business on
their own.
Seven common characteristics of 83 self
made millionaires in a 20 year study of
1500 men and women.
They followed them for something like 20
years to find out how well these men or
women would do in life.
Good question.
And they found at the end of the 20
years,
83 of the 1500 men and women had become
millionaires and they went back and they
studied the millionaires and they found
these qualities and characteristics.
They found out.
Number one is that none of them ever set
out simply to make money or to become
rich.
Many of the others who did not become
millionaires set out and they had one
goal in life and that was to make lots
of money.
I made it everything humanly possible in
that 20 years to make lots of money and
not one succeeded.
The ones who didn't set out to become
rich,
just set out to do something that they
really enjoyed and they became totally
absorbed in their work and the word that
they use throughout the study is
absorption.
And I pass this on to you because in
every case where I've seen a successful
man or woman in business,
they have been totally absorbed in what
they're doing.
They've just been completely involved.
They were not speculators or risk
takers.
There was not one investment scheme,
not one speculation,
not one gamble,
not one stock market method.
The only people who made money
consistently and became wealthy
consistently were the ones who are doing
an excellent job making a lot of money
and then holding onto the money when
they made it.
Sometimes they say success has a bigger
destroyer than failure.
We suddenly have successes and we
started throwing the money around and we
get into things that we don't know
anything about and then we get into
those things and they start sucking up
additional funds that we have,
but we can often go broke going down a
side road.
Most became millionaires almost
unknowingly.
One year their accountant said,
by the way,
do you know how much you're worth this
year for it?
And said,
no.
They said,
you're worth a million $100,000 it
couldn't believe it,
and finally they did not make their
money investing.
They made their money doing their work
and if they invested,
they invested their money in their work,
in their business,
in their own companies.
They didn't invest it outside.
The conclusion the researchers reached
after 20 years of study was simply,
this is it.
You'll always be most successful doing
what you most enjoy.
This is the greatest barometer doing
Whenever you think of a business or if
even if you're in a business now and
we'll do some testing on this in a few
minutes,
you ask yourself this question,
do I really enjoy what I'm doing?
People say,
well,
I don't enjoy it,
but I'm going to stay at it till I make
a lot of money.
I remember a woman came to me and she
was having great trouble in the real
estate industry.
She said,
Brian,
I've done everything that you said.
I've set goals.
I've worked toward those goals.
I managed my time well and and so on and
said,
but I'm still not achieving anything
near what I want.
She said,
I haven't sold the house in three
months.
I said,
well,
what is your goal?
She said,
I want to win the million dollar award.
I want to be the very top of the
multiple listing service.
I want to win that price.
I said,
well,
what would you do if you did win that
million dollar award?
She said,
Oh,
I'd quit this lousy business and get
into something I really liked.
I said,
well,
that's the problem.
She said,
well,
I hate this.
I hate real estate.
I hate selling house.
I hate the hours.
She said,
but I'm determined to stay in if I'm
successful,
and I explained to her that in every
single case,
if you don't love what you're doing,
you're not going to be successful at it.
The three keys are know what you're
doing,
become excellent in your chosen field,
believe in what you're doing and love
what you're doing.
Those three,
we'll guarantee you success more.
Sure.
Faster in life than any of the three
keys that I've ever seen in all the
literature.
Okay?
Five key abilities of successful
business people.
Number One,
judgment and judgment comes simply from
making mistakes and learning from them.
They say that every single wise,
intelligent,
mature individual was once young and
impetuous and foolish and did wicked,
senseless,
brainless,
cruel,
idiotic things.
That's how they became wise and mature.
It's scars and pain that make you wise
and put the little crinkles in your
corners.
So the key thing is not avoiding making
mistakes because you're going to make
mistakes,
but to learn from every mistake.
This is the hallmark of leaders.
They never use the word failure.
They'll use the word mistake though you
back.
They'll use glitch and they find that
the people who move ahead the fastest
are the ones who make the most mistakes
the earliest and learn the most lessons
from them.
Now the something about nature and the
business world,
it is very unrelenting in that if you
make a mistake in business and you don't
learn from it,
nature will enable you to make that
mistake again and if you don't learn
from it the second time in nature,
we'll keep putting you through that
hurdle or over that hoop and throwing
you flat on your face until you learn
the lesson and you say,
okay,
I got it.
I finally learned it.
I'm not going to do that anymore.
And then you have judgment,
then you have wisdom.
Then you go on to the next hurtle.
Remember,
the hurdles never stop.
The most successful multimillionaires
and billionaires that you read about in
the newspapers and the magazines have
fights,
struggles,
battles,
setbacks,
obstacles,
defeats disappointments every single
day.
The difference between winners and
losers is that winners pick themselves
up,
learn what they can salvage the very
best they can from it and carry on.
And losers think that these mistakes,
these setbacks,
these heartaches are happening to them
for the first time in history.
Watch for the trends.
Many successful business people say that
trend analysis is the most important
single skill of the business person,
which means foresight to think what's
likely to happen in the future as a
result of what is happening today.
Leadership is the ability to inspire,
to elicit extraordinary performance from
ordinary people.
Leadership is a key quality,
uh,
of successful business people.
And remember,
you can only inspire others to the
degree to which you are yourself
inspired and others,
you must be really excited about what
you're doing.
If you expect to inspire others to be
excited about helping you do what it is.
And all great businesses have inspiring
leaders at the head of the businesses.
Communications ability is absolutely
critical for successful business people,
which means three things.
The ability to interact effectively,
one on one,
the ability to make presentations,
to stand up in front of groups or to
make presentations to lenders or to make
presentations to customers and the
ability to write effectively.
Peter Drucker says the three key tools
of the executive are the report,
the presentation in the meeting.
And if you are poor at any one of those
areas of communications,
you owe it to yourself to become better.
Finally,
sales ability,
the ability to influence,
persuade,
motivate people to act in a certain way.
I'm always astonished when people come
to me and they say,
I want to start a business,
but a,
I need to get somebody who could sell
the product for me.
I tell them,
if you don't have somebody who can sell
the product for you,
don't put a penny into the business.
There's a thousands,
a million products out there that are
not moving because there's nobody to
sell them.
The ability to sell is one of the rarest
qualities in all of business enterprise
and all the big successful companies in
the world spend millions of dollars a
year training their salespeople.
So if you are not good at selling and
you want to start a business or you want
to build a business,
you owe it to yourself to become good at
it.
You owe it to yourself to back off and
take the time to practice because all
sales ability is learned.
Some people say,
well,
I've just don't have the gift of Gab or
I'm not a good salesman.
Nobody was a good typist when they
started.
Nobody could ride a bicycle when they
Nobody could drive a car when they
started.
Nobody can run a computer when they
Nobody could sell when they started
either.
They all learned.
The key is this,
is that if there are skills that are
essential for success,
your job is to learn those skills,
not to deny it,
not to delay it,
to,
not to put it off,
not to find excuses,
but if you want to be successful,
you have to do it.
Okay.
Career advancement strategies,
what do we call the niche?
Strategy is terribly important.
It's based on an enormous amount of
research I did at the university and
that other people had done and it is
looking at your business environment and
saying,
what are the critical parts of your
business environment?
What are the areas that represent your
areas of strength,
but especially what are your areas of
weakness in a business?
You will find that it's like a chain of
business always collapses,
always breaks.
At its weakest link,
the business always collapses at its
weakest point.
And in looking at the purpose of a
business,
we know that the purpose of a business
to create a customer is to serve a
customer efficiently and economically.
Cashflow is the lifeblood of an
enterprise.
So if you're working for a company,
one of the things you have to decide is
if I want to move ahead rapidly in this
company,
I have to get myself into an area in the
company that is vital to the survival of
the company.
Does that make sense?
Because if you're in an area of the
company that is irrelevant to the
survival of the company,
you can never become valuable and
important and highly paid and
responsible.
So what we do is we know that any
interruption to cashflow threatens the
survival of the enterprise.
So we look at where is the biggest
interruption to cashflow likely to come
from.
Now,
usually the most important function is
marketing.
The most important single function in an
organization is marketing.
If sales stop,
the business collapses.
60 to 80% of all businesses that run
into trouble run because sales slow
down.
If marketing is the key area in your
company,
you owe it to yourself to become great
at marketing,
to get into the marketing area,
get into sales,
get into strategic market and get into
the part of the company.
It's important.
The second part that may be important is
finance.
If the organization that you're with is
dependent upon financial institutions,
it has to borrow a lot of money.
It has to raise capital in the stock
market.
If that's the key to its success and
growth,
then you owe it to yourself to get into
that area because the company's growth
will be determined by how successful
they are and if you can be fundamentally
important in that area,
you can really dramatically increase
your value in a short period of time.
The production area is very interesting
and I read a study actually done by the
University of Alberta where they went
into a brewery and they were looking at
this idea of critical environments and
they found that in the brewery,
the most important single function in
the brewery was the production area that
the breweries,
customers,
we're pretty largely fixed they delivery
system.
The distribution system was pretty much
established.
Its market share was established it
manufactured beer and sold it on a
regular systematic basis.
The only thing that could cause the
shutdown of the organization and the
cutoff of cashflow was if the equipment
broke down.
Now the equipment was maintained by the
maintenance engineers had meant that the
head maintenance engineer,
it was the most important single person
in the company.
He was more important than the president
and the who was the head engineer was
the highest paid next to the president.
He had the greatest perks because if he
didn't do his job properly,
the whole company came to a halt.
And this is often the case in
organizations that depend on production
distribution.
Food distribution is very,
very important.
If it doesn't get to the stores on time,
you know if it gets to the store is a
week late,
sometimes it's too bad you have to throw
it away.
Another example is fashion.
The people in the fashion industry who
are in control of the distribution,
the outlets,
the stores that sell,
the fashions,
moving the fashions from production to
the stores as quickly as possible are
the people who are key in the fashion
industry.
Why is that?
Is Fashions are timely?
If you don't get it to the right source,
get it there six months later in perfect
condition is not quite good enough,
isn't it?
If it,
how about record distribution?
How about distribution of books or
anything else?
Anything that can become dated?
The distribution function is vital that
people who are essential in distribution
become the most valuable people in the
company.
Research is important.
Look at Silicon Valley.
What is the most important single
function in Silicon Valley?
There's making people millionaires.
It's research coming up with new
products and processes.
They know that the market will gobble up
all the new products that they can come
out with if the products will serve a
market need.
It is coming up with the products,
so it's the engineers,
the technicians,
the research and development specialists
that are getting paid.
One,
two,
three,
four,
$500,000 a year and of course regulatory
environment.
If you have to work with government,
look at in Washington DC,
jam with lobbyists,
Jim with representatives,
senior representatives of major
industries and industrial groups because
they require protection,
they require a tax benefits,
they require relaxation of environmental
controls and so on.
Those become absolutely vital elements
within a business and finally labor and
the people who are superb at dealing
with Labor are critical.
Now.
I only reason I point out these points
by the way,
marketing,
finance,
production,
distribution,
research,
regulatory and labor is that in every
business you will find by checking one
of these,
that if you're having troubles in your
business,
the weaknesses in one of these areas,
if it's in your own business or any
other company,
that you can use this as a checklist and
say,
where are we falling down?
Remember,
the company always collapses on the side
of the weakest pillar.
All right?
Knowledge is power,
specialized knowledge or skills and a
vital area.
Enhanced promotability control of vital
information is power.
The more I learn that makes me important
to that company,
the better off I am and I learned a very
good lesson.
Very early is learn all you can.
Never tell all you know.
If you tell all you know,
then what happens is they don't need you
anymore.
Strive for excellence.
Be the most knowledgeable person in your
chosen area within the organization.
Do it quietly and pretty soon the
rewards will start to flow to you.
Okay?
What are the reasons for business
failure?
In my estimation there are 14 major
reasons for business failure.
Number one,
reason for business failure,
lack of direction,
the failure to establish specific goals
and plans to achieve them.
If you don't have specific goals,
what you do is you become reactive.
You are either acting on your
environment or you are reacting.
Most companies in my estimation,
95% are in a reactive mode in that
they're not acting at all.
They're just simply reacting to what
happens every single day because they
don't have clear goals and plans to
achieve them.
Lack of a complete business plan is a
major reason for failure.
You know why that is is because the
ability to put together a business plan
is a major act of business competence.
The reason people don't put them
together,
it's primarily because they don't know
how.
The reason that they fail is because
they don't know how.
When they develop the competence to put
together a business plan,
they also develop other competencies
that go with it.
Impatience is a major cause of business
failure.
Trying to do too much too soon,
trying to cover too much greed is a
major cause of business failure.
A very good friend of mine,
very successful consultants that Brian,
the secret to success in business is to
get rich slowly.
Don't try to get rich all at once.
Get rich a little bit at a time.
Do it slowly.
If you're going to get rich,
waiting an extra year isn't going to
hurt you.
More people lose their shirts because
they get involved in what you might call
a get rich quick scheme,
something that's going to make them rich
in hurry and they're not going to have
to do a lot of work so they plunge and
the plunge sets them back sometimes five
and 10 years in terms of their savings.
Number four,
action without thinking,
as Peter Drucker says,
is the cause of every failure.
Action without thinking impetuousness is
the cause of every failure and
especially not listening to your
intuition,
not listening to your gut feeling.
One of the most important things that
you have is intuition.
If you listen to your gut feeling,
it will almost always give you the right
answer,
especially with regard to people.
Do not ignore your intuition with regard
to other people.
Five for cost control,
overspending,
especially at the beginning,
almost invariably when people start a
business,
they will buy things that they would
never think of buying if they'd been in
business for six months.
Basic rule at the beginning of a
business is save every single penny.
The basic rule is simply this,
conserve cash,
conserve cash every day.
Get up in the morning and say,
what can I do today to conserve cash?
Biggest mistakes that I've ever made in
business are plunging into two and three
and five year leases right at the
beginning of a business and then finding
that the business won't sustain it.
Poor quality of product,
nothing will sink of business faster.
It's difficult to sell and it's
difficult to get repeat business.
Many people think,
well,
if it's,
it may not be a very good product,
but uh,
I'll sell lots of it and then I'll make
some money and then I'll do something
else.
The fact is that the more you advertise
a poor product,
the less it works.
The more you advertise a good product,
the better it works.
So don't ever handle a poor quality
product.
Don't ever justify trying to sell a poor
quality product because it's going to
come back to haunt you in sufficient
working capital,
which means an expectation of immediate
cash flow.
The biggest mistake that people make is
they think that they're going to have
positive cashflow in 30 to 60 days.
They talked to people and people
reassure them.
I think it's going to be all right.
And the key there to remember is that if
you set a break even point,
you need six months capital in order to
open up.
If you don't have six months of capital,
then open up on a smaller scale and
second of all take whatever you consider
to be your break even point.
So you think you're going to break even
in three months.
Multiply that times three.
The law of three comes out in every
single study of business,
in every single product or process.
Always take your most conservative,
most reasonable break even point and
multiply it by three is that far more
realistic and make sure you have enough
capital to last that long.
Number eight is bad or nonexistent.
Budgeting,
failure to develop pro formas and
budgets for operations.
Many people actually start a business
and embark upon what we call guaranteed
losses because they haven't done
budgeting and they haven't worked out
how much it's going to cost and how much
they're going to have to pay.
They haven't worked out that they're
making a loss on every single item that
they're selling.
You've heard the old saying of the
phone,
he says,
I lose money on every item I sell,
but I make it up on the volume.
Do you know how many business people
actually operate on that and because
instead of sitting down and doing a pro
forma working out all their costs,
all their expenses and how much they're
likely to have at the end in terms of
profits,
they find that in many cases they don't
have any profits at all and yet they're
working their heart out.
They can't understand they're doing so
much business but they're going broke
day by day.
So just the fact that you draw up
budgets and pro formas is a very,
very good discipline and we'll show you
how to do that later.
Inadequate financial records,
most accountants will tell you surest
way to go broke is to treat your
bookkeeping as though it were an
irrelevant sideline through all your
receipts in a box and get to them at the
end of the year.
One of the things which I do recommend,
by the way,
if there's,
if you're not good at bookkeeping,
don't do it.
Hire somebody else.
Number 10 major reasons for business
failure,
loss of momentum in the sales
department,
which leads to a loss of cashflow and
the collapse of the business venture.
So number one reason for business
failure.
Yes,
people get too busy doing other things
and they think that sales will just keep
on coming in and Lo and behold,
sales are like watering a pump.
You're going with that.
You keep pumping the pump and the water
keeps flowing.
What happens if you stopped pumping the
pump?
The water stops flowing with sales and
marketing,
you have to be pumping that pump all the
time.
The instant that the strong executives,
the most important people take their
hands off that pump.
The sales and marketing effort just
burns to a halt and the whole company
falls apart.
I worked for two companies now that got
so carried away with their success that
they became administrative companies and
they felt that sales but just come to
them because they had established
themselves in the marketplace.
Now,
it was a matter of setting up
administrative systems within nine
months.
One company that went from zero to $3
million in business in four years that
men are worked all their lives for that
opportunity.
They built their company.
They had made it in life.
Nine months later they were dead.
I business consultant came in and told
them,
what you have to do now is where do you
work on administration?
Set up your internal systems,
your internal controls.
I got so carried away with it.
Nine months later,
the company was dead.
All the top salespeople left and the
market has turned their back on them and
walked away.
Well,
failure to anticipate market trends,
changes in demand,
changes in customer preference,
changes in the economic situation.
When gasoline prices go up,
what's that going to do when interest
rates go up?
What's that going to do when the real
estate industry increases or decreases?
What does it going to do to your
business?
Watching economic trends is very
important.
Number 12 lack of managerial ability or
experience.
People just simply don't have the
experience or the ability to be in
business.
People don't know what they're doing.
They don't understand about pro farmers.
I don't understand about budgets.
They don't understand about selling or
marketing or advertising and long
behold,
most cases,
they won't take any advice either.
So you can always get experience or
ability if you do it slowly,
but if you try to do it all at once,
what you do is instead of accelerating
your career,
you set yourself back five or 10 years
didn't decisiveness is a major reason
for failure.
The inability to make decisions in the
face of difficulties.
Things start to go wrong and what do you
do is you put off making hard decisions.
Another thing is inability to make
decisions,
delaying decisions because of fear of
hurting people's feelings,
keeping on incompetent people,
staying in business.
Relationships that aren't working for
fear of hurting somebody's feelings is
one of the major causes for failure in
small and medium sized businesses.
Isn't that interesting?
Interesting statistic came out of some
very large consulting studies that were
done a few years ago is that if we
cannot immediately cut off the deadwood
and keep working with only people who
can do the job,
chances are they'll drag a sender and
afterwards you know what they'll hate
you for having kept them on for so long.
Bad human relations with staff,
suppliers,
creditors,
95% of all business failures come from
an inability to get along with other
people.
Number 14 which underlies everything is
diffusion of effort,
lack of priorities,
going off on tangents and the inability
to concentrate on doing the right things
and doing things one at a time.
Now,
what are the reasons for business
success?
So there's 10 reasons for business
success,
many of which are the converse of the
reasons for business failure.
Number one is the product or service is
well suited to the needs and
requirements of the current market.
Very important.
Number two is there is a complete
business plan developed before
commencing business operations.
The development of a business plan,
although it is laborious,
is a sign of managerial competence.
It tells you and it tells the world that
you're qualified to start a business.
The inability or unwillingness to
develop a plan tells the world that you
are not competent.
Number three,
a complete market analysis is followed
by a development of an advertising,
promotion and sales program.
In other words,
you sit down and you determine who is
your competitor,
who is your market,
where do you sell,
who buys,
why they buy,
what benefits they buy,
what you do better,
where you're going to sell to and so on,
which we'll talk about in a subsequent
session.
Uh,
and then you design your sales programs
and work it out.
Let me give you an example.
I went,
sat down with a person who was going to
open a store in a shopping center and we
went through the financial analysis.
I was trying to lease them in the space.
As a matter of fact,
I went through the financial analysis
and it turned out that that person would
have to have something like 38 customers
a day,
spending an average of $25 per person in
order to survive selling the products
that they were selling.
And their average sale was $12 per
person.
And it was a small rural shopping center
and they would never be able to survive.
I just worked him through it based on
what you have to sell in order to
survive.
You're not gonna be able to do it in
this location.
And he said,
no,
no.
He said,
you don't understand.
And he opened the store anyway and he
lost five years to say it went broke six
months later.
So the financial analysis and the
marketing analysis is important.
Tight financial controls,
good budgeting,
accurate bookkeeping and accounting.
The basic rule to remember and running a
business and I've worked with some of
the most successful business people in
the world is frugality,
frugality,
cheap,
pinch every penny until it screams,
be very,
very careful.
As we said before,
conserve cash.
Go cheap,
every single penny that you possibly can
buy used equipment,
used furniture,
use carpeting,
rent,
youth space and so on would be very,
very careful about expenses.
A high degree of competence,
capability and integrity on the part of
the key staff.
Very important.
Hire only the people you need and hire
people who can do what you need them to
do.
Don't try to train people on the job,
especially in a small and medium sized
business.
Good internal efficiency,
good time management,
clear job descriptions,
clear and measurable output
responsibilities.
In other words,
everybody knows what they're supposed to
do,
knows the most important things they're
supposed to get done and manages their
time well in order to do it.
Number seven is determination,
persistence and patience on the part of
the business owners,
the business principles.
Number eight is good communications
amongst the staff and open door policy.
The better.
The communications,
the more everybody knows within an
organization they better that
organisation functions.
We find that in every single case where
you have a problem organization,
you have secrecy,
you have poor communications amongst the
staff,
poor communications,
up and down.
People are playing it.
Cool and your big companies like IBM and
Hewlett Packard,
everybody's on a first name basis.
Everybody can have any information they
need in order to do their job well.
Number nine,
strong momentum in the sales department
and an emphasis on marketing.
Everybody thinks marketing all the time,
which leads us to number 10 a concern
for the customer at all times is a top
priority.
Every single successful company that
I've ever seen has one characteristic
amongst all the people in that company.
It's love for the customer,
love for the customer.
They love their customers.
They are very concerned if a customer
has a problem or a complaint or a
difficulty,
they're are very,
very concerned about it and you'll find
that right from the switchboard all the
way through.
When you call a good company,
they treat you like you're really,
really important.
I used to work for a large department
store chain that subsequently had a lot
of financial problems.
The clerks would be so busy doing their
busy work behind the counters that when
a customer actually came along,
they'd be irritated.
They look up as though you were actually
interrupting them.
They had lost all sight of the fact that
all of the arrangement of the counters
and the mirror,
today's and everything else was for the,
when the customer came in and what
happens is they treat customers in
differently.
They'd say,
oh Geeze,
well I can't do that now.
I'm going on coffee,
or could you hurry up?
It's almost my lunch break.
I was doing some consulting with a firm
just last week where the manager was
appalled.
Somebody came in to buy $800 worth of
merchandise at a quarter to five that
had to be installed and it took about 20
minutes to install it and the person
says,
I'm sorry we can't take the business.
You'll have to come back tomorrow
because we shut down at five o'clock and
it takes 20 minutes to install it.
They turned an $800 customer or ways
that we never know,
never knew where that customer ever came
back or not.
But uh,
it was certainly disconcerting to find
that there are people doing that.
We spend a fortune advertising to get
them to come in and they come in and
they want to buy and we tell them to go
away because it's just not convenient
right now.
Do you know what the person had to do?
They had to go drinking at five o'clock
with their buddies and they didn't want
to be late.
So be very careful about that.
Those are the reasons for business
success.
Now what we're going to do is a very
brief exercise.
I'm going to ask you to answer some
questions and these questions are very
important.
They're important for now.
They're important for tomorrow,
they're important for the future,
and they enable you to focus on the very
most important things that you could or
should be doing within your business.
And I'm going to give you one minute to
answer each of these questions and I
want you to write them as fast as you
can.
Write the first things that come to your
mind.
Don't think about it.
The first number one question is list
five jobs or fulltime activities paid or
unpaid that you have done in your life.
Let's the first five that come to mind.
Just five jobs or full time activities.
Anything that you've done,
whether it's been paid charitable,
whether it's been in school,
whether it's been a with a social
organisation politically right.
The first five fulltime activities that
you have engaged in since you left high
school,
however many you have now go quickly to
question number two and write down the
one thing that you enjoy most about each
job or fulltime activity and the order
that you wrote the jobs.
Write down what you enjoyed the most.
What parts of the work did you enjoy?
What Park gave you the greatest amount
of satisfaction in that work?
When you look back on it,
what makes your heart glow,
if you like or makes you happy when you
remember that particular activity?
I go to question number three again,
thinking back over the jobs,
what did you do best in each job or
activity?
What were you best at?
What part of the job or activity did you
do the best for you,
the most capable?
And if you were doing five or 10
different things,
what part of it did you excel at?
But part of it where you at the very
best at your performance,
your skills,
your capability,
where the very finest and that
particular area of the job.
Now go to question number four.
What was your major accomplishment in
each of those jobs are fulltime
activities?
What one thing did you accomplish?
Why is it a technical thing?
Was it an interpersonal thing?
What thing did you achieve that you
remember the most as being the highlight
of that job?
Uh,
or activity?
Just think through if in in retrospect
the one thing that you did or the one
thing that you accomplished or achieved
successfully in that job.
Even if it was just learning the lesson,
uh,
learning something important,
something of value that you got
additional training,
whatever it happens to be,
write it out as quickly as you can.
All right,
go on to the next question wherever you
are going to the next question.
Now list five activities,
experiences,
events,
or situations in your life that have
given you immense personal satisfaction,
a feeling of importance of self liking
and self worth.
It could have been getting married.
It could have been getting a degree or
graduate.
It could've been anything,
right?
The first five that come to mind as
quickly as possible.
My question number six if you could have
any job or be in any business,
what do you think you would enjoy the
most?
Imagine a billionaire who control a
variety of organizations came up to you
and said you could have any job you
wanted or be in any business in the
world.
Which one would you choose?
What job would you want?
Would you want to work for someone else?
Who would you want to work for yourself?
If you wanted to work for yourself,
what business would you want to be in?
What sort of position would you like to
have in that business?
Right?
The very first thing that comes to mind.
All right,
question number seven.
How much do you want to be earning in
one year?
In three years and five years?
In 10 years.
Very,
very important that you have an idea of
what these figures are and don't be too
concerned about how correct or how
accurate you are.
Just write down what you consider to be
a reasonable goal to achieve in the next
one,
three,
five,
10 years.
The wonderful thing about that is that
95% of people walking around,
we'll never write down a financial goal
and their whole life and they cannot
understand why they did not improve
their financial conditions.
The very taking of that exercise that
you just did moves you into the top 5%
in the world in terms of future planning
and you will be astonished.
I've had people take that exercise and
never look at it again till two years
later and then open it up and look at it
and say,
by dog gone it.
They have achieved those financial
goals.
Just writing it down,
programmed it into the brain and over
the previous two years,
the opportunities to achieve the
financial goals came to them.
All right.
Question number eight and the final
question in this session.
Imagine that we had a bottle of pills
that guaranteed you against failure and
the question is this,
what one great thing would you dare to
attempt if you knew you could not fail,
each of you would get one of these
pills,
you can take this pill,
you'd be guaranteed of success 100% of
any one thing that you attempted in your
world,
especially in your business and your
career world,
like one great thing would you aim for
if you absolutely knew beyond a doubt
that you could not fail,
right?
The first thing that comes to mind,
the answers to the on what jobs you did,
what you accomplished in those jobs,
what you enjoyed most will be a very,
very good indicator of what you should
be doing in terms of your work,
in terms of your career,
in terms of your future planning.
Very often we find ourselves doing
something later in life,
which is very different from all the
things that gave us joy and satisfaction
at earlier periods in our life.
And we wonder why we are not excited
when they get up in the morning.
The key is to go back and look at the
things that you've done before that
really made you happy.
They really made you feel great about
yourself,
that gave you a feeling of importance
and self esteem and try to structure
your activities.
So you're doing work,
uh,
kind of work with the kind of products
and the kind of people in the kind of
environment that recreates those
experiences that for you are unique and
that will enable you to achieve
everything you're capable of achieving
in business.